if you're trying to build a desktop
application in c plus plus finding a
good gui framework to use can be tricky
i mean don't get me wrong there are so
many different options out there you
could use something like qt or wx
widgets i mean they seem to be popular
they're cross-platform what's the
problem the problem is
i hate them i mean does anybody actually
have a good experience using like qt or
wx switches to build a cpu plus
application not to mention the complex
licensing model that goes behind some of
these that might cost you quite a bit of
money so what do you do what do you do
if you just quickly want to make an app
in cbos plus why is everything so
difficult well before we answer that
question let's step back a little bit
why are you using c plus plus to build
an application because if you're not
there are so many things you could use i
mean if it's just something simple then
maybe you could consider writing a web
app that runs in like a web browser
that'd be easily cross-platform out of
the box including mobile devices and
really anything with a good web browser
and if you wanted to be more desktop
focused with that kind of ease of web
development situation then why don't you
just use something like javascript and
electron i hear it's great for the more
serious applications you could use
something like c sharp and wpf i mean
yes you'll be restricted to windows only
but maybe that's okay i could go on the
point is there are many different ways
to build applications you don't have to
use c plus and in fact i would say c
plus plus is kind of an unusual choice
unless you're like me if you're building
a performance intensive application or
something that's low level or something
that really highly revolves around a
library maybe that's written in c plus
and using wrappers or whatever is just a
pain and you want to just write an
application in c plus instead you know
for those use cases it really does make
a lot of sense to just write your actual
kind of application gui part of
everything in c plus so as an example
for those of you watching this channel
you know that i build game engines a
game engine what is a game engine a game
engine is basically like this
c plus plus core or at least it is in
most cases that then has stuff built
around it to facilitate the production
of games as an example so since the core
is in c plus plus and usually that core
will adapt to whatever platform you want
it to adapt to so whether that be
windows mac linux maybe mobile devices
maybe consoles that core
is very intrinsic to the application
therefore it makes a lot of sense to
write any tools that might go along with
the chord that really rely on the core
such as an editor which needs to
actually have like a viewport that is
the core running inside it as well as
adjacent tools it makes a lot of sense
to write that big tool i'm talking about
the editor in c plus now you don't have
to
i worked at ea for almost five years
they have frostbite frost ed the
frostbite editor is written in c sharp
wpf it of course uses the frostbite c
plus core but the actual tools are
written in c sharp so even if you are
writing a game engine of course you
don't have to write your tools in c plus
however as i mentioned the downside with
c-sharp wpf is that it's windows only
which is okay for a company with
proprietary technology such as ea
because their development teams can just
use windows and in fact in the games
industry most people do use windows i'm
not talking about the indie developers
with their cool macbooks i'm talking
about like triple a developers usually
run on windows now unity and unreal are
two very big engines very popular
engines that have the core in in class
plus but then also the tools or
specifically the editor is also written
in cbs plus unity has a bit of a c-sharp
thing going on with a lot of plugins and
all of that but the core kind of
rendering framework is still there in c
plus and if you want to be
cross-platform and if you are a game
engine that already has a lot of
rendering going on in my opinion it
makes a lot of sense to write your
editor in c plus plus and to also be
using a gui framework that uses like
immediate mode rendering using your
graphics api the reason being that you
are a game engine like you are rendering
things in real time you're doing
graphics intensive work it's totally
okay for you to use that same tech for
your application ui anyway game engines
aside what if i just want to build an
application as people's bus why is this
so difficult what is the easiest way for
me to get up and running that is what
i'm here for today i just want to show
you guys what i do when i want to build
an application in c plus plus how it's
incredibly simple and way easier than
anything else i've tried and out of the
box it's not only cross-platform
including like mobile devices and
consoles but it can also adapt to any
rendering api you might be using directx
910 1112 opengl vulcan metal and you
only have to write your code once and
it's completely free in open source
doesn't this sound too good to be true i
am of course talking about i am gui or
dear i am gooey which is an absolutely
wonderful immediate mode gui library but
wait isn't im gui some kind of like toy
you know debug ui thing for like testing
out applications just something like
really simple that can't be used to
build big applications no
it's not it's amazing and it can do
pretty much anything now i will put a
little disclaimer here just because and
that is like i don't want this to turn
into like a retain mode versus immediate
mode versus hybrid kind of uis and like
what what the best thing to to use is i
firmly believe immediate mode uis are
just superior but i also acknowledge
that it does depend on what you're doing
my specialties in game engines game
engines as i mentioned are very much
real-time rendering dynamic machines so
for what i do i think it's totally okay
if you are trying to be extremely
efficient on some kind of low-spec
embedded device or something like yes
maybe you don't need to render the ui
every frame and be all responsive and
stuff but i would argue that right now
in 2022 for most cases immediate mode
uis are just better but isn't imgui like
really limited and you can't style it
very well and it just doesn't look good
no
where do you no because you're literally
rendering everything as if it was a
video game like you can do literally
anything this is what hazel's editor
looks like this ui is completely written
in i'm gui yes we did have to modify
some parts of i'm gui to actually make
this happen but we are still using i am
gui and it is still great to be honest
the only area where i start to see
problems with i'm gui are like if you
have absolutely huge data sets if
they're all being kind of rendered
refreshed every frame you might run into
some problems but there are always
strategies to mitigate that you can just
use caching in some form however in our
experience in hazel like for example if
we have like hundreds of thousands of
objects in the scene or something the
bottleneck has always been our code so
for example like we need to show details
in a tree view and to get those details
we have to hit like the asset manager
and other engine systems to retrieve
those details those have usually been
the bottlenecks not the i am gooey
rendering code my point is it's very
fast anyway enough talking this has been
quite the lecture but i just wanted to
explain to you guys what is going on in
a minute we're going to dive in and take
a look at how to actually write an
application in i'm going but first i
want to mention that this video is
sponsored by hostinger hosting is pretty
much the best web hosting platform on
the internet if you need to host a
website or if you need a server for
something to do on the internet hosting
it is your go-to maybe you don't need to
use c plus to write your application
maybe you can write it as a web app how
are you going to host that web app using
hostinger we use hosting it to host
hazelengine.com which by the way you can
go to to find out more information about
hazel the game engine that we're
building setting up hazel engine.com was
an incredibly simple process like you
just press a few buttons fill in some
details such as like you know the name
of your website pick your operating
system and it's pretty much ready to go
and that simplicity applies to if you
just want like a shared hosting website
deal or if you're using a vps like we
are and not only is the actual like ui
and dashboard and all that beautiful and
simple they also have a ton of useful
documentation that will help you get
going or do something really specific
it's not only useful if this is your
first website i mean i've set up a lot
of websites in my day but just coming in
and finding out the specifics of this
web host in like just a few words on
their documentation is so refreshing but
i guess having such a nice clean user
interface and brilliant documentation
you probably have to pay a lot for that
right
no hosting as prices are honestly insane
they're honestly the best value web host
i have ever seen click the link in the
description below to sign up if you use
the coupon code cherno you'll get an
even bigger discount and i promise you
you will not be disappointed huge thank
you as always to hosting out for
sponsoring this video so as i mentioned
let's dive in and take a look at how we
can make a c plus application using i am
gui this is the i'm gui github
repository this is where it all begins
now the only thing i want to point out
here apart from the fact that if this is
your first time you know you should read
the readme all that stuff maybe get to
know the library
there are two main branches there's a
branch called master there's a branch
called docking the rest are just like
feature branches but these two as you
can see are kind of like the main the
main events now
docking
even though it's not the master branch
is a very mature usable branch that has
been around for like years eventually it
will be merged into master it's not
merged into master at the moment though
and it has a lot of really really useful
functionality such as a dock space so
that you can dock windows like you would
in many applications these days as well
as being able to drag windows outside of
the viewport as you'll see when i show
this later in this video so my advice is
to use the docking branch now in my
opinion this docking branch is really
what makes imgui actually useful in the
real world for real applications if it
wasn't for that kind of being able to
drag windows outside of the main window
and also you know doc dock spaces all
that stuff uh i probably wouldn't be
making this video today recommending
that you use i'm going for applications
because without this it would be a
little bit weird so let's obtain this i
have prepared a folder
here it is called i am gui apps uh if
you just click on the little address bar
type in cmd to get to a command prompt
let's go ahead and clone i'm gui and we
will start from there so let's go ahead
and grab that url we'll go over here get
clone i always do a recursive clone just
in case there are sub modules that we
need to obtain i actually don't think
i'm going has any but we'll do a request
clone anyway we'll paste in the
repository url you don't really need the
dot yet it'll add it if it's not there
uh and then i'm gonna check out
specifically that docking branch
straight away so if you do a dash b we
won't bother checking out master and
then we'll have to switch to docking we
can just check out docking and then if
you like you can give it like a folder
so i'm gonna call this my application
it's going to check out all of this code
into a folder called my application
enter and now it's going to clone i'm
gui okay done that didn't take much time
let's go ahead and go to that folder
here we are here's my application and we
have all of our code here now
i am gui works pretty much anywhere
because it has a lot of really good
examples and you can see over here just
how many examples it has if you're just
doing a speed run and you just want to
get up and running with imgui then just
open the imgue example solution pick
literally almost whatever you like so
for windows i recommend either falcon or
like directx 11 or 12 but this isn't
exactly a speed run so let's talk about
this a little bit these example
directories have essentially like
the boilerplate examples for each
platform and library right so we have
win32 like directx 10 for example this
is using the win32 api to actually like
create the window and handle all the
events and then it uses directx 10 as
the rendering apis the graphics api so
glfw opengl 2 for example will use glfw
as the windowing and event library and
all that and then it'll use opengl like
version 2 compliant code to actually do
all of the rendering there's even m
script and stuff here so you can run it
on you know the web uh there's metal so
you can run it this will probably just
be a mac os version but they do have
like ios and android example somewhere
else here's an android example for
example the point is there's a ton of
stuff here and then not only is there
this but they now have a back-ends
folder this used to be part of examples
that contains the actual back-end files
for all of these my point being that
it's really easy to integrate this with
literally anything and that's the beauty
of this that's what makes this so
amazingly cross-platform the fact that
they just have example implementations
of everything and you don't have to do
anything yourself right all you really
have to do is open up this imgue
examples.solution now i'm going to
upgrade all of mine to like the latest
because i'm using visual studio 2022 and
i think this is still 2019. let's go
ahead and drag that into here it's
upgraded all the projects cool that
should be pretty straightforward and
then as i mentioned we pick something so
as an example i'm just going to pick
gelfw vulcan let's set that as a startup
project if we wanted to to keep things
clean we could unload like literally all
the other projects and i mean this is
where like if you were actually writing
an application like you were writing
your own application using imgui maybe
you wouldn't start with just you know
modifying this example solution if you
want to see a video on how to actually
create a project from scratch using i'm
going let me know i'll probably do that
but otherwise this is just going to be
faster so you'll see basically five main
files in this kind of example glfw
vulcan
main is the entry point as it implies
this is what has the actual like main
function if i can find it over here
right there's our int main it's got a
bunch of gel of w boilerplate code and
see this is where it's so amazing this
is why i love i'm going so much as well
because not only is it an amazing gui
like library framework whatever
it's also a fantastic kind of example of
how to get up and running with all of
these like apis like whether you're
using glfw for windowing or sdl or win32
here's a beautiful example of how to set
up glw create a window set up vulkan for
it and then render ui to it right so if
we just hit f5 this is going to be a
debug build but it doesn't really matter
for us this is what we get right this is
basically ready to go
right we have a beautiful application
and as i mentioned because this is the
docking branch we can literally take
this and just drag it out of the window
and you can see it's now its own window
this is impossible in the main branch or
in the master branch this is why
again as i mentioned like this kind of
functionality is great i can drag it to
my other monitor i can treat it like it
was a normal application which is
amazing and then under examples we've
also got that dock space right now it's
a dock space now i can dock this in here
and you can see suddenly we have a very
like real looking application but it's
all running in i'm gui it's all
rendering like you know well in this
case add v-sync i'm on a 144 hertz
monitor like it's all rendering like
real-time frame to frame every frame is
is rendered from scratch you know we
have a good immediate mode ui ready to
go so how do we kind of convert this
into our own application well
from here you could literally set up
anything you wanted to right and there's
even some useful comments being like you
know if you if you want your own font
because that's a common request i'm
gooey's default font is a bit you know
debug
looks like a debug ui thing um
you can change that easily obviously and
then we have like again very well
annotated the main loop here so inside
the main loop we have some important im
gui commands that have to happen at the
start of each frame so i am gui impulse
vulcan new frame glfw new frame and then
finally i'm gooey's new frame once you
finish these three lines of code within
that main loop this stuff is basically
rendering all of the ui that we just saw
so let's just say we're not interested
in this right and then it goes all the
way down to the actual rendering code so
that we also need to keep
so over here now
is where my code goes here
right so within this now we could set up
our own ui so to demonstrate this in a
little bit more of a kind of robust way
i'm going to create a new file now i'm
not sure where this will go exactly
because i don't know where the directory
is it's okay we'll just put it in here
um i'm going to go ahead and create a
new item and this is going to basically
be like our application like ui stuff so
i'm going to create a new file just to
keep it clean and simple so you guys
know what i'm talking about new file new
new header file there and a new cpp file
you know if i wanted to well let's just
keep this simple right i don't want to
be all over kill here let's just create
like a namespace called my
app um and then we'll create a function
called like you know render ui or
something like that
nice and simple let's go back to that c
plus plus file
there's our render ui and then over here
you know as long as we include
i am gui and i don't even know how this
was including that i am gooey so let's
go take a look okay so like this
basically all we need right over here
now i can like create a window so i'm
going to begin and you know
let's just say this is going to be my
like settings panel or something
i create that window
i'm going end to end the window and then
we can like add a button
hello
let's add like a
drag float so we can have like a
static float value
we can have like some kind of thing that
we
drag around this is just an example
obviously um
that's our settings panel done render ui
so if we go back to main let's just
include that application window or sorry
that application file that we just made
application.h and then we just do my app
render ui
f5
and we now have that settings panel i
talked about
right but what about the dock space so
you can see there is no dock space this
is actually vulcan rendering a clear
color in the background here which again
is is another perfect example
you know if you are in fact writing an
application that revolves around
graphics rendering this is where it's
great to use i'm gooey as well because
you you basically have all the vulcan
boilerplate stuff done you can start
rendering whatever graphics you like as
well as have ui stuff easily on top of
that and that works really well
obviously so how do we set up that dock
space in fact how do we do anything in
i'm gui well i am gui has a fantastic
file called imguidemo.cpp
which is huge it's like 8 000 lines and
it has examples for everything that you
might want to do
so let's let's go ahead and simulate a
scenario in which i don't know what to
do how do i create something well the
first thing is let's go back to our app
right i'm going to go ahead and just
type in i am
show demo show demo window f5 right so
now we're not only going to get our
settings window we also get that demo
window now within this demo window you
can just have a browse so like
basics you know here's like some stuff i
might want oh i want to make a tree how
do i make this whole tree thing right
and because these all have strings
obviously that are rendering you can
just search for these strings within the
file so for example basic trees let's go
to that imgui demo file and search for
basic trees here it is right and we have
again the actual code that was used to
render this specific like tree
so again as an example we know that we
have a dock space somewhere here and
it's gone ahead and made it on the main
window here so let's just search for
dock space this is an example
for docking and dock space right so show
example app dock space so again i'm
going to just literally copy like all of
this now there's a menu bar here and
there's some stuff that we probably
don't care about but let's just copy the
whole thing anyway we'll go back to
application
i'll put it at the at the beginning here
so then we'll just strip it so what
don't i want so if like again p open is
not really a required parameter here we
can replace it with the num point
because we don't want to close the thing
show docking disabled message like we
don't need that stuff sure we'll keep
the menu bar um
was this a menu item again we can
probably just strip some of this stuff
we don't care about like help marker
well this is the close option i'm not
going to have a close option done right
and then i'll take my settings panel and
put it within the dock space like that
we can get rid of the show demo window
and then suddenly just like that we have
a dock space we have this and guess what
it's now dockable so we can just dock it
over here
again to extend the example of a game
engine let's just say i have a viewport
panel as well
right so i'm going to make another
viewport window i'm going to go ahead
and dock this
into here there's my viewport docket
into the center and guess what i
basically already have like my game
engine up and running i just need to
render my stuff in vulcan or directx or
whatever i'm using to a texture to a
frame buffer and then just display that
image inside this im gui viewport as
just an i'm gui image right that is
literally done uh and then of course if
you close this and then reopen it it's
going to save old layout and that gets
saved inside an imgui.ini file so it's
basically like ready to go it's such a
simple thing and
and
because we've kind of segregated
everything into this application
uh you know
into these two application files
let's say that i don't want to use
vulkan anymore i want to use directx 12
right because that's i don't know for
whatever reason maybe i need to or i
want to or whatever i can go ahead and
just like grab these two applications
now of course this is not like the best
architecture like you probably want like
a static library or something with these
things but for now i'm just going to
copy application.h and cpp into here
right i'm going to set that as my
startup project we can like unload that
vulcan project entirely so it doesn't
get in the way and then again i'm going
to go into main
i'm going to include
application.h and then i'm going to go
into like the main function you know i'm
going to find my well i'm going like
render is kind of what i'm looking for
there's my rendering code there's that
example ui code and then we have the
same pattern you know dx dx 12 new frame
win32 new frame i'm going to frame so in
between these two let's do my you know
the my app render ui f5 now it's
building the directx 12 example using
the win32 api of course my ini file like
didn't get carried across so i'll have
to reset up the layout but you can see
that's that's it
like that's up and running but that's my
directx 12 example and of course if we
wanted to
customize that text a little bit we
could just change the title to like my
app or something and then now we have my
app up and running with everything so
really simple this was practically a
speed run i apologize if i went very
fast and as i mentioned this is not like
you know the best architecture but this
is just how you get up and running with
im gui
really easy and from here of course you
can build literally any application you
want it doesn't have to have any
rendering right i don't want to i don't
want you get the wrong idea like you
don't have to render 3d graphics in this
viewport you can but you don't have to
you could this could be a calculator app
right it doesn't matter but the point is
uh it's just really easy to get up and
running works on every platform any like
device really
and yeah i don't think i need to say
anything else but you know me i will say
something else uh if you want to
actually see where the app was like
created to and you want to distribute
this for whatever reason let's go back
to like debug or i'm just going to one
of these things to see where the exe
file was output to let me just make that
a little bit wider so you can see i like
to use this output console sometimes to
just quickly grab the path so this is my
exe file that we were debugging there
there's a debug build you'll probably
want to use a release build but anyway
here is my like directx 12 example uh
let's actually do something cool though
i like that layout let's go ahead and
grab that iron gui ini file
and we'll pop it into this debug thing
and overwrite this one just so that we
retain our layout and that's it right we
now have our application there's a lot
of like debug symbols and stuff that we
really don't need um it all builds into
a static library right so this little my
app situation my app
is now literally just this exe file and
this ini file right if we grab that put
into an isolated directory so it's clear
what actually goes into this rename this
select my app
we've made an application we've made a c
plus application that is like two
megabytes again this is a debug build so
i regret everything it'll be much
smaller and much let's actually do that
let's just build a
let's make a release build i just did a
build all which is not what i wanted to
do let's just build this specifically
and again it's just going to put it into
the release directory here it is 473
kilobytes let's go back to our my app
and
uh
we'll just delete that replace that
enter there's our release build up and
running done
ship it it's literally ready well
actually we do get that console window
though so maybe i'll take back my
regular ship thing let's go back into
the release configuration here and to
link a system and we will just set this
to be windows instead uh let's go ahead
and rebuild that now we will get a
linking error over here because of win
main i'd honestly the i feel like the
win32 example should definitely include
that instead but you basically have to i
don't remember the win main like
function but for windows application you
have to use uh the win main entry point
so let's go ahead and
quickly we don't really need all this
fancy stuff do we f5 just double check
okay now we get um
no console being allocated there which
is good so if we go back to my app and
uh go ahead and go into release copy
that
you know the drill
paste it in my app enter no console
ready to ship i can't believe it's not
butter i mean i can't believe that was
that easy if you want to see some more
content around i'm gooey definitely let
me know as i mentioned i can go a little
bit deeper into how to actually set this
up from scratch not using their examples
but you know how you would set it up if
you had like an existing library or game
engine or something like that or if you
want to see some more like styling stuff
so how to get it actually looking nice
and how to get it to look more like
hazel all that stuff let me know as well
hope you guys enjoyed the video hope it
was helpful to you hope this will help
you out with your c plus application
development if you need a website or a
web server definitely check out
hosting.com
the link will be in the description
below i will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you